Olá eu sou do tempo de uma medicina que
tinha bip quando eu terminei a faculdade
que precisava fazer atendimento de
urgência os pacientes ligavam para uma
central essa Central transmite a um
sinal de um bip literalmente assim quero
um negócio imenso que a gente carregava
na cintura no cinto e que tocavam EA
gente tinha que parar onde estivesse
Descobri um telefone fixo para entrar em
contato com a central para pegar o
recado da família do paciente do
hospital seja lá quem estivesse com a
necessidade de uma orientação médico e
depois a gente fazia a ligação para
pessoa que tinha pedido esse atendimento
era um tempo onde havia urgências mas
não havia pressa não tinha como que
e essa como prioridade a minha turma da
Faculdade de Medicina da Universidade de
São Paulo foi a primeira que teve
informática médica eu aprendi a fazer a
programação de histórias clínicas no
doce era tudo muito lento eu fui uma das
primeiras a usar a internet e aí era
internet discada que a gente tinha
também a prática da paciência em relação
a isso a pesquisar a clínica na pesquisa
de artigos para o aprendizado para
incrementar aprendizados era feita na
biblioteca Com base no papelzinho a
gente descobrir ali qualquer O tema é
termos técnicos né de busca e
encontrávamos a revista preenchemos o
papelzinho esperavam as duas semanas
para ter o xerox do artigo que a gente
precisava usar naquele tempo né quando
eu era criança tinha uma série já tinha
série quando era pequeno que era tinha
um Age
e seis e O Agente 86 ele tinha um
celular que era o sapato dele e aí os
anos foram foram passando e chegou o
celular para gente nesse mundo da
assistência ao Cuidado então o bipp fez
saiu do barulho para o texto Tinha
mensagem de texto no bico e depois
passou para o celular O celular era algo
grandão apareceu um sapato mesmo a gente
falava que era um tijolão teve um tempo
onde a tecnologia começou a desabrochar
dentro da área da assistência à saúde de
uma forma que encantou muito Os
Profissionais de Saúde do mesmo porque
não os pacientes né eu lembro a minha
irmã tinha uma doença neurológica grave
e ela fez a tomografia na década de 70 e
80 nos primeiros tomográficos que
chegaram no Brasil e a gente foi se
encantando com a tecnologia se
encantando com a tecnologia até que
chegou um momento onde era possível ter
é a vida humana pelo aparelho nós
abrimos mão de examinar o paciente
cuidado paciente entrar em contato com
os olhos dele conversar com a família
para olhar para um exame olhar olhar
para uma tela de computador a olhar para
uma tela de celular a tecnologia estava
se tornando um obstáculo a prática de
humanidade dentro da assistência à saúde
a e agora nós vivemos num tempo muito
raro dentro da história da Saúde onde
nós precisamos do recurso tecnológico
para colocar em prática a nossa
humanidade a pressa ainda está presente
o afeto estava muito raro antes da
pandemia o acesso aos médicos que
tivessem condição de monitorar e
orientar um cuidado muito mais complexo
ficou mais desafiador porque não dá mais
para gente viajar e a telemedicina se
instalou como um grande recurso de
assistência
e eu pratico cuidados paliativos eu
tenho formação em cuidados paliativos e
cuidado para ativar uma área da
assistência que aborda o sofrimento
humano de uma pessoa que está diante de
uma doença que ameaça à continuidade da
vida e nesse tempo todo eu tive a chance
de cuidar de pessoas que eu nunca toquei
nas mãos delas porque eu fiz assistência
remota Muitas pessoas ficaram dentro do
hospital sem nenhuma chance de ter em
contato com suas famílias e é o contato
com essas pessoas tinham com os
profissionais de saúde eram contatos
intermediadas por toda aquela
Parafernália de proteção né mas os
equipamentos de proteção individual que
aparentemente deixavam esse paciente
absolutamente isolado vivemos a situação
de impedimento dessas famílias e
chegarem junto dos seus entes queridos
que estavam internados que estão
internados ainda a gente Ela está
vivendo esse contexto de extrema grave
Ah e ainda assim não tivemos a chance de
sermos subversivos' em relação ao uso da
tecnologia antes das ar dessa condição
de inviabilidade do contato humano a
escolha por utilizar o recurso da
tecnologia como parte do contato parte
da proximidade era algo que depende dos
elementos de cada um eu me lembro de um
momento com os meus filhos no domingo
que eu adoro domingos e o domingo tava
livre e fez o almoço com Várias Vários
pratos né porque cada um tem a sua
preferência fiz tudo e tava aquela pia
cheia de louça e aí Terminou de almoçar
cada um foi pro seu computador para o
seu celular e aí eu podia ter uma
atitude de uma mãe típica e falou assim
poxa eu fiz tudo para vocês e vai comer
o almoço hoje eu não trabalhei trabalhei
bastante essa semana para poder tar
livre no domingo tratar com vocês e
vocês não nem se importa
Oi e aí naquela fração de segundo eu fiz
o mal uma escolha uma escola de usar
aquilo que eles consideram importante
como um caminho de proximidade eu mandei
no celular ele tem um grupo Nosso três
eu mandei no celular Oi e aí tu enfim
eles olhares olhando para mim dar uma
risada e responderam no WhatsApp Oi Aí
eu escrevi tô livre
Oi e aí eles fizeram uma careta
responder ao careta no WhatsApp e E aí
Oi e aí eu decidi escrever não sabe se
alguém quiser lavar louça eu posso fazer
companhia
E aí foi uma das partes mais divertidas
que a gente teve porque a escolha de
utilizar a ferramenta tecnológica como
uma ponte já poderia ter acontecido
antes mas agora é o único caminho que
nós temos
É nesse momento nós temos milhares de
pessoas internadas no país que se sentem
muito distanciados do seu espaço de
humanidade sendo assistida se cuidadas
por profissionais de saúde e que a
utilização do recurso da tecnologia
trouxe para esse encontro entre paciente
e profissional de saúde a chance de
viabilizar o afeto porque através desta
ferramenta agora da tecnologia que nós
encontramos a única forma de expressar
afeto eu teria chance nessa pandemia de
cuidar de muitas pessoas como eu disse
sem poder tocar a mão delas e essa
chance eu não abriria mão por nada
e é muito difícil fazer isso sim é muito
difícil mas quando a gente tem na nossa
frente um único um único caminho que
possibilita a realização daquilo que não
sabemos fazer nós não podemos abrir mão
desse recurso cuidando dessas pessoas de
uma maneira remota eu posso proporcionar
elas a percepção de que elas são
importantes incluindo as famílias nessa
assistência nós damos a possibilidade
dessa pessoa se sente única por causa da
história dela ela não é mais um número
ela não é mais uma pessoa doente no
mundo ela é a pessoa muito amada que
pode encontrar nesse recurso que a
medicina agora tem acesso também do
ponto de vista humano como uma forma de
se sentir realizada na sua vida mesmo no
momento de adoecimento
bom então agora que nós não temos mais a
opção de abraçar de estar próximo de
visitar nós vamos Não podemos perder a
chance de fazer bom uso desse recurso
que todo mundo tem eu vi uma pesquisa da
Fundação Getulio Vargas dizendo que
temos 234 milhões de smartphones
espalhado pelo Brasil então a chance de
termos uma pessoa que tenha esse recurso
como uma forma de viabilizar sua fé Tu é
muito grande então eu sugeriria que
depois de me ouvir cada um de vocês
pudesse pegar o celular agora escolher
alguém na agenda
bom e você olhar para aquela aquele nome
ali me lembrar de todas as coisas boas
que você viveu com essa pessoa e eu
tenho certeza que você vai poder sorrir
e quando você fizer isso E aí você manda
uma mensagem pode ser mensagem de texto
os vídeos assim preciso dizer que te amo
O que é por causa desta ferramenta da
tecnologia que hoje muita gente pode
dizer isso e seu ouvido muito obrigada
E aí